hey what's up everybody this your boy
david lucas and welcome back to another
episode of flat lion at dickboy studios
[Music]
i'ma read some of the jokes that you
guys sent in last week that i thought
and the rest of my team thought was
pretty funny and you guys let me know in
the comments if you think they hit or
not
so here's the first one david looks like
a gumball machine repairman
fairly decent
dave is the type of guy to get a punch
card at the abortion clinic which
i can actually see myself doing that
cause i ain't trying to have no more
kids
when people say dave is the next patrice
o'neill they mean the next comma to die
of diabetes hey you mean mother
you know what watch your mouth dog
that was pretty good though patrice is
one of my favorites
so guys i don't know if you've seen it
or not but they're actually doing a
reboot
of the fresh prince of bel air
and i'm a little disappointed because
all these people that they got to play
the new characters in the fresh prince
look like sims characters
like the guy playing will smith looks
like diggy simmons i don't know if y'all
remember diggy simmers like come on dawg
you look like you skateboard and date
white girls with purple hair like i
don't believe you got enough swag to
replace will smith
and the guy that they got to replace
phillip banks
like how you gonna replace a fat man
with a skinny dark-skinned man
come on bro y'all replace philip banks
with idris elba
and and they they did unveil a little
justice because you know all of the real
fresh prince of bel air fans like
you know if you like me grew up in the
90s you knew that the dark skinned that
viv was better than the light skin ever
but they went back with a dark skinned
available so i can't really complain
about that
now carlton
is where we got a real problem because
carlton you all know was a geek and they
replaced carlton with a guy who actually
looks like he got swag like he looked
like he might have a studio in his
parents basement
like carlton looked like he sell incense
and sell mixtapes
hillary banks uh they did all right man
you know hillary's a character ashley
banks can't really talk about ashley too
much you know both of them still cute
but then you got uh the butler jeffrey
they really replaced uh
jeffrey's character with the guy who uh
married uh
russell simmons ex-wife the guy who
played in that uh amistad movie he looks
like that guy
jazzy jeff uh jazzy jeff
his new character uh i don't know bro he
kind of looked like a tupac from juice
if you ever seen that movie
man let's get the first one
what's up boy
what's up man your ass look like a
mexican johnny bravo yeah you do your
recipe with that same one last night man
hell yeah stuck hair right what the [ __ ]
wrote you boy
what
this ain't no time to get acquainted
what [ __ ] you talking about what you up
to you know what i'm saying hey bro my
bad i'm just trying to beat johnny bravo
out here
i'm roasting yo ass wait like you slept
with a mouthpiece in last night your
teeth is pushed back boy
hey bro you lie you wake up too you look
like you wake up to a dumbbell to the
face what the [ __ ] roll with your mouth
well you got a snake mouth like you just
eat raw eggs for fun
your ass look like a legless lizard get
the [ __ ] body here
that one
yeah that was a good one yeah boy
you look like you're saying spanish
doo-wop music
[Laughter]
well you gotta you got a big toe on your
face
there's no denying that brother bro you
got it you got a kneecap nose
you got a party nose
hip hip hooray
mexican tightrope walker that's going to
be hard to beat this time david
oh that's what i told you last time
yeah
let me say it again you look like a
mexican tightrope walker
i see elia gonzalez finally grew up what
the [ __ ] going on bro
[Music]
elite gonzalez how was it floating to uh
cuba on a on a race car tire
that boy got the cuba his first dinner
was beans and rice
that boy went to bed with gas and pride
hello hello
yeah i know you like man
oh shout out the lord brother yeah i
know you like me like a [ __ ] boy
look at that
you bro you can't you call me with no
shirt on you probably ain't got no draws
on you probably sitting on the shoe box
you little gay [ __ ] are you wearing a
shirt bro that shirt is blending in dude
well yo yo ass got a glow in the dark
condom on top of your head [ __ ] wrong
with you
you look like an edm dj bruh
thank you brother yeah you look like you
hang out with calvin harris
what you got in your hand bro
vape
oh shout out
what you got in your lap a cat
nothing else
nobody got no drugs though you nasty boy
are you a [ __ ] i show you nothing else
bro you're a nasty pervert bro you're
going to jail
bro you like you just got out of jail
for beating the [ __ ] out of your wife
[Laughter]
what are you in the room with
myself
oh i thought you had some kind of
composite with you you know starts being
good
that was decent
you look like you get turned on you look
like you get turned on to the sounds of
acoustic guitars
yeah well you look like you're a [ __ ]
banjo
man your lips look like red dogs
what that mean
the red hot dog
oh red links
yeah red oh okay okay if you just said
that that would but we know it red
though
like red dog you know red dog when you
kick a dog in the ass and his ass turn
red that's red dog
what else you got dog
oh
but i ain't got no man you the
professional yo spirit animal is toby
keith
[Laughter]
[Music]
well you look like the whole foods
employee of the month
take it that way that boy rent a room in
a haunted house what the [ __ ] you have
why are you in transylvania ain't
[ __ ] going out of your house dog
you like you about to take them glasses
i'll go in the phone booth and turn the
metrosexual superman
superman with straight teeth and [ __ ]
with a gluten allergy
i've seen you before
what's good david lucas yeah bro you had
a mixtape with a ace hood and rick ross
dj khaled i knew i knew you dog oh
yeah everybody call me dj
another one
dj cauliflower you look like somebody
bro
talking about rappers you like grimace
started becoming a rapper
you look like you sitting in a
timberland booth get your ass out of
here your ass is comfortable in a work
boot
you gotta stay
you gotta steal toe recliner get the
[ __ ] body here boy
with you dog
lunch monitor my guy with that shirt on
you look like a black hole like if you
go into your stomach you'll go 1200
years in the future
you look like a black hole
bro your teeth are so spaced out they
look like prison cells
[Laughter]
your mouth look like solitary
confinement boy about ugly as [ __ ] boy
you got uncle bubba teeth in your mouth
[Laughter]
yo ass dude before and after pictures at
the dinners for a living
hey man thank y'all for watching another
episode of flatline man this your boy
david luke is live here at thick boy
studios we're doing it again next week
make sure you watch my instagram in the
thick boy studio instagram so you can
get that link so you can come roast with
me you know what i'm saying and make
sure you got your jokes ready man i
still don't feel like nobody hit me good
i'm waiting for somebody like ugh give
me a nice little gut punch man all right
man y'all be good and make sure you
leave your comments in the youtube
because i'm reading the best comments
live on there every week all right man
peace